Donald Trump has a history of
criticizing the people that are brought
to the White House by other presidents
President Obama is an example the entire
Republican Party went crazy when it
appeared as though maybe President Obama
was going to possibly open a dialog with
Fidel Castro but President Obama never
asked an admitted multiple murderer to
come to the White House to hang out
which is exactly what Donald Trump did
he invited Filipino president Rodrigo
Duterte
to come visit him will Republicans say
anything about this Duterte has of
course as I've told you about received
worldwide condemnation for most people
there's a couple people that like it but
for the most part he's been condemned
for sanctioning me completely
extrajudicial killing of drug users and
dealers in the Philippines a White House
release on Saturday said that Trump and
duterte had a quote friendly discussion
about Southeast Asia and the drug war in
the Philippines and Trump requested that
duterte come to Washington and Trump is
looking forward to the visit remember
that duterte has admitted to when he was
mayor of I forget the name of the town
he would just kill people on the street
and this is the guy pad that Trump had a
lovely conversation with and wants to
visit with at the White House yeah it's
a really tricky issue to comment on
because you got to draw a line somewhere
as to which leaders you should and
shouldn't allow into the White House no
past presidents have met with leaders of
the Soviet Union or Saudi Arabia and
even though it's controversial maybe
those meetings can be productive but if
you're going to draw a line somewhere I
think someone who is a rogue admitted
murderer is where you straw that line or
at least when you press release it say
you know we don't just paint a rosy
picture of the relationship between
Trump and those brutal killers say
something like end of even if it's not
true and of course we condemn the
admissions that what the killings that
Duterte has admitted to casually and we
believe that it's an absolute atrocity
human rights organizations have recorded
over four
1300 murders of people involved in drugs
in the Philippine people who are
supported by duterte many of these
murders have included homeless kids and
Duterte had said that up to a hundred
thousand people suspected to be linked
to drugs should be killed and he
actually likened himself to Hitler in
the past remember when Rodrigo Duterte
said quote I'd be happy to slaughter
them at least if Germany had Hitler the
Philippines would have me Trump is
friendly with and is inviting for a
visit a guy who said he could be like
Hitler was to Germany and I don't know
if it was odd to see a David but he
yesterday Donald Trump said that he
would be honored to meet with kim jong
hoon i saw that yeah North Korean
dictator so that's another one I assumed
that or I guess I do assume that if
Rodrigo Duterte comes to the White House
they'd have turkish President Erdogan
Skype in or something like that because
him and Kim jong-un and why not put
Bashar al-assad in there with the time
difference it may be a little bit hard
to coordinate on skype you know my guess
is that Kim jong-un and odo on are
keeping sort of bizarre day-to-day
schedules that's my guess I don't know
don't don't hold me to it drug wars are
bad enough but this is so far beyond
that what we're talking about Rodrigo
Duterte participating in here and don't
forget that Trump also has clear and
strong business ties in the Philippines
Trump's partner in building Trump Tower
at Century City in Makati Philippines is
a member of doTERRA Ches administration
and yesterday we made some comparisons
between Donald Trump and Kim jong-un
sort of trying to figure out why would
Donald Trump praised Kim jong-un for
just being handed power by his dad in
tenth big similarities to Donald Trump
Duterte said last year quote just
because you're a journalist you were not
exempted from assassination if you're a
son of a [ __ ] and although Trump isn't
calling for the murder of journalists we
are seeing him wanting to crack down on
the First Amendment over stories that he
doesn't like and duterte has also called
Vladimir Putin his idol which again
Donal
Trump hasn't done but he's been pretty
deferential to Vladimir Putin so I am
actually as shocking as it is at face
value
I'm not hugely surprised that Trump has
been praising Kim jong-un and praising
Vladimir Putin in certain instances and
wanting to hang out with Rodrigo Duterte
who he has a great relationship with
praising president Erdogan and Turkey
for his repressive actions it sort of
fits yeah I think he is a little bit
jealous of these other world leaders who
have less of a restrain on their ability
to govern I think he wishes that he was
more of a king or a dictator because
that's the role that suits his
personality a little bit and it's the
role he's had in his business right and
he came in thinking that he was going to
run the government the same way he was
running his business fortunately that's
at least not happening to the extent
that Trump would like it to and I've
been digging pretty low here to find
some kind of silver lining